シャアうわあああああああああもういいよもういいぞ
座っ明日ずもう何毛布でプレイヤー
ん
[音楽]
はいうん
ああ今ここをとビクターのいいなんですけども彼は今
いませんなぜかといった猫の写真を撮ってこようという新しい企画に出ていますと
ミックカーンと僕が猫の写真を撮ろうというちょっと意味不明が企画をやってという体
で僕ととミクさんにも本当は外に出てるんですけども僕だけこっそり帰ってきて今この
松屋していますドッキリをしようと思いますなぜで自分の顔が印刷されたボールが
トイレにめちゃくちゃ大量に入っているドッキリでございますよ
というわけでプラントトミックボールでございますスターこう250個入ってるので膳
2000円3000円4000円
400には110キロ以上のトリッカーの顔が支えたボールに返します
パパッ日
開けてみましょう ua
あっはぁ
ああああああ
回トミックボールこんな感じでございます
あっはい的でこんな感じのとミクさんの顔が言われずボールが今こちらに4000が
あるのでトリックアンの部屋の一つをこのボールでいっぱいにしたいって僕はむかと
ミカンねもっと自分を愛する共通
使ってほしいので今どぅミクさんが多分猫の写真撮ってると思っております
[音楽]
ブーブーいきますウードゥー
ああああああ
[音楽]
13ん十分編ざーせん
うーんまっ
やばいもう九段ボールが限界をに下がってきましたちょっともできないと基づいてそう
です
[音楽]
はいこれくらいでございます
うわぁやばいなせーの
はっはっは絶対絶対に行きますよね by 空間していて夏の予断を許さない状況です
扉限界まで行って圧迫されてるんでちょっとでも揺らしたりするともう
とミキサーが前に出てきてしまいますまーす
されてもらいながらと力さんの帰りを待ちますて後ミキサーの海で待ちましょう
取れました猫
20 p 約13匹いい
ダイヤ2全体で僕を待っていておりますけどねしょん
打ったのはそれはさと良さまあ1階の広い借りしましょうや
よな者でも滑る時も良いくらい小上がり出すん
お肉さーん
トイ開かないんですけどまず開かないんですけどそれを試し
ん
なんかめっちゃ方へ持っ
ですね傘持っているとかと思っ
めっちゃ硬いですよ re re re re re re re
マジでこれまずお前さ
気持ち off
me
[音楽]
あっはぁ
でもこんなに
yeah yeah
こんな子が深くないですよねまーすっ
貼っていく飛び込みたくないんですねこの子の取引含む
ran